I've never forgotten anything else
start off with a slightly styled red
four five day old was left over it is
Perfect
The Lost life
delicious
chili
[Music]
um
[Music]
a couple tablespoons of water in there
[Music]
look at me
again
[Music]
spicy deliciously
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's something
perfect
[Music]
[Music]
over
all right
then I'll push again
[Music]
no I love Hot Pot you love Hot Pot
and you love sausages right yeah what'd
you enjoy most about sausages
um I just love having them with a baked
beans sometimes with baked beans
sometimes these are
button mushrooms okay you just take them
into there like that
we keep the hall and cut them into
quarters please now the important thing
about cooking sausages is they need a
bit of color right no color no flavor
exactly get the pan nice and hot how was
school today school was good thanks we
got to go out and make snowmen sausages
in
okay butter mushrooms in there please my
darling
see
now
going to watch your fingers but you know
how to slice onions right definitely
definitely now sausages
I get in lots of color because this is
going to cook slowly
and it's sort of Daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one
nannies to make for me yeah
yeah once you've got the color on them
and take them out
the rest okay
a little knob of butter okay into the
pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so that'll go down by half give that a
little fry okay salt in
I want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
packed with flavor this feel nice smells
nice washrooms in give them a nice
little stir
did you like to help me make your hot
pot when she made them for you I used to
always help now make the hot pot
always now my mum would never have used
this but A's balsamic vinegar brings out
the flavor of the onions right now look
at her onions look beautiful caramelized
the vinegar has given that nice sort of
gloss I'm gonna put my sausages back in
here now from there
some red wine
red wine in
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
does that look beautiful smell and it's
still not cooked yet up to the ball
really important to boil it here because
it won't boil in the oven 170 in the
oven literally
18 to 20 minutes and she goes nice
to go with my hot pot Rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and I'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly slice potatoes and
cook beetroot
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
foreign
with a neat layer of potatoes and pour
the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot gratin are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the Apple compod what we need to
do first is to get these Peels and
sliced
I got my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
foreign
okay and you need to cook them those
wonderful red apples you've got are
called Brae Burns what other apples do
you know cream ones what are they called
um
another word for your nan
Grandma's no
red no pink lady apples no Granny Smith
Granny Smith apples that's right what
we're gonna do is cook the cooking
apples and
the eating apples together I love the
combination of the tartness from the
bremly cooking apple with the sweetness
of the Brae bun get the pan nice and hot
and sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
I want you to remember that because
we're going to look for them okay
because once we use them and they've
worked their magic I need to pull them
out see all the sugar dissolving
now we just let that go a little bit
darker
okay and then
replace it quick doesn't it
give that a nice
little toss
okay a nice golden color cinnamon in
ginger in so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cooking till the apples soften
then take off the heat
let me go into there what's that coming
out damp so that is a little bit of the
puree I'll show you we'll do that in a
minute how many Ginger
four four Ginger
three cinnamon three cinnamon out with a
cinnamon
the ginger gingers and take
spoon
of apples
bottom smells so nice how nice is that
look see the color of the apples
these in the fridge to get nice and cold
that's the Comfort sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to Crown the top you
separate the egg whites into there for
Daddy
right egg whites are in I think it's
separate off you got away
[Music]
and I'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
good girl
[Music]
there's your place now let's see if
you've got a really nice stiff peak so
you lift them up
and that is what I call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad next in a
separate Bowl whip double cream until
stiff
nice and slowly
so cream whips so much quicker
yeah
nice
we're gonna put some delicious lemon
zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compote puree you mix
that in nice and carefully
so it's like this apple butterscotch now
to make the cream even lighter fold in
those whisked egg whites and sugar egg
whites
into the cream
just
nicely fold that in
so we bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep
good girl
silly we're on for a treat open up the
Piping Bag now twist the end now you
could spoon this in I don't want to just
give a nice little lift it also gives it
a nice
lemon on top
fridge
the beetroot and potato gratin is that
lovely that's lovely sausages oh
finished with a flat leaf parsley
look at those two beauties it doesn't
get any more comforting than that does
it for one of the best hot pots
ever Tilly that looks amazing
in there well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by Apple compot
food with guaranteed feel-good Factor